My goodness - this is insanity.
Earlier, when running an experiment with 25
ChatGPT AI agents playing a video game together
in a simulated town, absolutely magical things
happened.
What happened?
Well, they planned their days, formed relationships,
invited each other to parties which they also
organized, and more.
I absolutely loved this paper, and my goodness,
here is an even crazier one.
It has an insane idea.
If these AI assistants can have their own
identities, motivations and they can converse
in full natural language, why not ask them
to form a company to develop video games!
But, how does this even work?
Well, each of them get assigned an identity,
for instance, we can say that you are going
to be the CEO, little AI, and you are going
to be the CTO.
Then, they can make decisions together, and
perhaps even more importantly, they reflect
upon these decisions later and evaluate whether
they have done well.
So, what did they do?
Look!
They have indeed taken on roles, we now have
a CEO, and teams designing, coding, testing
and documenting.
There is already a crazy bombshell in this
image, I wonder if you Fellow Scholars have
noticed it.
I’ll tell you about it in a moment.
Now, they also established a chat chain that
describes who gets to talk to whom.
This will encourage teamwork, I love how the
programmers are already taking instructions
from the CTO.
But, it doesn’t stop there.
Here comes my favorite part!
Oh yes, cross-examination!
Another little tester AI is looking at the
programmer’s solution, and says look, I
have found a bug!
And when it comes to problems, they are quite
picky.
Then, they can make suggestions as to how
to improve the program some more.
This is incredibly important.
Why?
Because of one word: hallucinations.
ChatGPT is known to make up answers from thin
air every now and then, and here, we have
another one looking at these hallucinations
and saying, wait a minute.
This is not quite what we are looking for.
So, does it work?
Yes!
It works spectacularly.
Finally, we have someone writing the manual,
and of course, at the end of the chain, the
user installing the game, running it, and
evaluating it.
Here you see how they go from getting comfortable
with their roles, to brainstorming, to writing
code.
Loving it.
Now, here is a five in a row game that they
wrote, first without a graphical interface,
and then the designers iterated on it.
All of which were AIs.
So good!
Now, what was the crazy thing in this image?
Oh my, look at that!
They are even using the waterfall software
development model.
The authors of the paper argue that it is
a well established model for software development.
However, it is a rigid model where identifying
errors late into the development process may
not allow us to fix them.
And they still managed to create something
usable together.
And hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because all this happened in less than 7 minutes,
and it costs less than one dollar.
Wow.
Bravo, little AIs!
Now, five in a row is not the only game they
can write together, here is the process for
pong as well.
Great!
But, wait a minute.
Are five in a row and pong the only games
they can write?
Because these are games that are out there
in the wild, many people have written them
before.
Is it possible that it is just copying this
code from somewhere?
Well, Fellow Scholars, I have two good news
for you.
Good news number one is that the source code
of this project is available, so you can create
your own AI game development company, and
good news number two, other Fellow Scholars
already have done it.
So, I am itching to know the results, so now,
… oh my goodness.
Look at that.
They can write many different programs.
Todo tracking apps, password generators, maze
generators, even a video player, and so on.
And note that many of these use GPT3.5, which
is not even the smartest version of GPT yet.
Wow.
What a time to be alive!
So, these little AIs can not only play together
in a video game, they can even write the video
game themselves.
And what if we would ask them to write a video
game and put themselves in it?
And perhaps do it recursively, so their video
game versions would also develop a video game
and so on?
Now that would make one super fun experiment,
hopefully we will see that in the next paper.
Also, I find it very surprising that if we
think about GPT as a virtual brain, which
is quite a bit of a stretch, but bear with
me for a moment, and perhaps the best use
of it is to split it up into different little
brains with different identities and have
them work together.
That is a crazy thought…but it works.
I love it.